[Music]
welcome back to our Fox News virtual
town hall America together returning to
work here tonight live from the Lincoln
Memorial in Washington DC we are joined
now by President Donald Trump good to
see you sir well thank you both very
much we never had a more beautiful set
than this did we that's right thanks for
doing this this is a little different
than our last Town Hall in Scranton
Pennsylvania yeah that's true it was a
beauty questions from around the country
but and a lot of great questions I want
to start with this though mr. president
there is a real split in the country
there are folks out there becoming
increasingly angry about the closures
there are many Americans also who are
angry about the reopening they're
fearful as many of these states are on
the rise in their numbers
there's 66,000 deaths more than that now
as president what do you say to the
people who are scared to go back to work
on one side and what do you say to the
people who are really angry about these
lingering closures well I think you can
satisfy both have you scared you're
gonna stay back a little bit and you're
gonna watch it and I think anyone over
60 because we have pretty good we have a
pretty good road map right now anybody
over 60 you could say 65 but let's make
it 60 we have to protect those people
and we have to watch it and maybe they
stay back longer but no I think you can
really have it both ways I think a lot
of people want to go back they just want
to go back you see it everyday you see
demonstrations all over the country and
those are meaningful demonstrations oh
it's big stuff but you also have some
people that are very scared now probably
everybody scared when you get right down
to it it's a terrible thing a terrible
thing that happened to our country it
came from China it should have been
stopped it could have been stopped on
the spot they chose not to do it or
something happened either that was
incompetence or they didn't do it for
some reason and we're gonna have to find
out what that reason was but people are
absolutely scared but there are other
people that are scared about being
locked in a room and losing their job
and not having any income and you know
for the first time these are workers
these are people that want to get back
and work and make a living and they're
afraid their job is not going to be
there and at a certain point if you keep
it going too long that's going to happen
so I understand that very
well on that note let's hear from our
first video questioner this is Shana
crews from Coleman Alabama mr. president
my name is Shana crews and I'm a single
mother from Alabama I lived paycheck to
paycheck before the virus but then I
lost my job in March I haven't received
a stimulus payment or anything from
unemployment I'm behind on every bill
about to be evicted from my home and
I've had to rely on donations in order
to feed my children I'm feel frustrated
and I feel scared not knowing where to
turn or what to do what advice do you
have for me and others in my situation
is there more help coming number one
there's more help coming we have really
no choice because incredible people like
this are it's not it's not your fault I
mean just remember that it's not your
fault and there is more help coming
there has to be and we want to get it to
a point when we open we're not going to
lose businesses and therefore more
importantly frankly we're not going to
lose the jobs that run the businesses so
a case like that is it exact you know
it's really that's the reason why we
have to do more and we're going to do
more and everybody wants to do more it's
really it's actually on that aspect of
it it's very bipartisan so the answer is
yes we're going to do more and you're
gonna have your job you're gonna get
another job or you're gonna get a better
job you get a job where you make more
money frankly and I think that's going
to happen I think we're gonna have an
incredible following year we're gonna go
into a transition in the third quarter
and we're gonna see things happening
that look good I really believe that I
have a a good feel for this stuff I've
done it for a long time we built the
greatest economy in the world the
greatest economy frankly Brett and you
can correct me if you'd like but you
can't because it's in fact the greatest
economy that the world has ever seen and
then one day they said sir we're gonna
have to close it I said what are you
talking about closing it nobody ever
heard that we're gonna have to close it
and we did the right thing we saved I
think we saved millions of lives but now
we have to get it back open and we have
to get it back open safely but as
quickly as possible you know let me ask
you about that because you've talked
about that moment quite a bit with just
this roaring economy and advisers saying
to you we've got to shut it down at this
point so when you look back on that
moment and you see some other examples
Japan for example did not do as broad a
shutdown
they've only lost
500 people out of newspaper hundred
thirty million you're right but now
they're doing a massive shutdown because
they've been hit very hard and so you're
right about yeah that's my question that
moment in your on the Oval Office and
say maybe we went too far no we did the
right thing I do look back on it because
my attitude was we're not gonna shut it
down look we're gonna lose anywhere from
75 80 to a hundred thousand people it's
a horrible thing we shouldn't lose one
person over this they should have been
stopped in China it should have been
stopped but if we didn't do it the
minimum we would have lost is a million
to a million four million five that's
the minimum we would have lost probably
higher than it's possible higher than
2.2 you know the way you have to look at
that I've never seen death like this
I've never personally experienced
anything like it and they talk about the
flu and all of that well I've known
people that had the flu all my life I
see I was looking I never had the flu
then I came here that want to give a flu
shot and I said I don't want a flu shot
but they have to give it but you know
what I've know people that had the flu
all of my life I never nobody ever died
I never had a friend he had the flu and
he died I've lost three friends one of
her a good friend a very successful man
New York guy employed a lot of people
they were all crying over his death
Stanley Shera
he went to the hospital calls me up
because I tested positive I said well
what are you gonna do he said I'm going
to the hospital I'll call you tomorrow
he didn't call I called the hospital
he's in a coma no I know a lot of people
that had the flu they were never in a
coma
this is a very advanced visit a very
horrible thing we're fighting but with
all of that said we still we've learned
a lot about it it affects older people
it affects if you have any problem heart
diabetes even a little weak heart a
little diabetes of this thing is vicious
and it it can take you out and it can
take you out very strongly but children
do very well young children do better
than you know teens so you think you've
learned from this how you've dealt with
it now yeah it comes up in the fall
you'll do something - yeah I will put
out the embers will put out whatever it
may be we may have to put out a fire I
tell you one thing we did the right
thing and I really believe we could have
saved a million and a half
and by the way just just to know what
that means we've seen death like
Elmhurst Hospital in Queens right where
I grew up right near where I grew up
note the building very well know the
hospital they had body bags lined up in
hallways they had body bags sitting out
on sidewalks
I've we've never seen that in this
country you saw the mass grave it's
called Hearts Island they built a mass
grave I've never seen anything like that
when you look at that and look at and
that's with let's say it's a hundred
thousand or ninety or ninety-five now
multiply it out
don't go 2.2 or 2.5 million say it's
half of that so take the numbers that we
looked at that nobody in this country
has ever witnessed and now multiply at
times 15 or 20 so instead of having ten
or twelve body bags laying on a hallway
you'd have 15 times more than that
that's the scary part for business
owners who are getting ready to open up
our next question comes from here in DC
and it's a topic we received a lot a
question questions about and that is
testing and what people have to do thank
you very much look it depends on where
you're coming from New York is a very
much different place than Montana or
many other states really where it's not
you know really too bad it's always bad
they lose anybody it's bad and every
state has lost significant numbers of
people I mean you know whether you're
talking about 20 people or 25 people
that's a significant number of people
but it depends on when you come from
certain states are gonna have to take a
little more time in getting open and
they're doing that some states I think
frankly aren't going fast enough I mean
you have some states that Virginia they
want to close down to the mineral of
middle of June and a lot of things that
they're doing I really believe you can
go to
ARC's you can go to beaches you keep it
you know you keep the spread you keep
you stay away a certain amount and I
really think the public has been
incredible with what they that's one of
the reasons we're successful that's one
of the review call losing eighty or
ninety thousand people successful but
it's one of the reasons that we're not
at that high end of the plane as opposed
to the low end of that number has
changed mr. president you said it's
going up I used to say 65,000 and now
I'm saying eighty or ninety and it goes
up and it goes up rapidly but it's still
going to be no matter how you look at it
at the very lower end of the plane if we
did be shut down you you said that the
governors would be kind of responsible
for the testing and we just talked to
Governor Hogan he says there is federal
assistance coming to get specific large
well not only coming we've given them a
lot of assistance which is good so your
son in law advisor Jared Kushner
declared that it's a great success story
the federal response it is and that when
you look at the other side that that
you're on the other side medically or do
you think that as debts are going up and
cases are going up that we really are on
the other side medically and that this
is a great success story from the
federal government well I can own well
it's too soon to say that really I guess
because you know we're still in the
middle of something but certainly we
would have lost a lot more people Brett
if we would have done as an example you
call it heard if we would have done hurt
in other words everything's wonderful
let's just keep going along per minute
we were the last two and a half million
people I think or a million and a half
or two million people no I think we've
done I think the American people have
done a good job there's a tragic
situation everybody knows somebody
that's been affected that's a very rare
thing but everybody knows some states
have done a better job than others I
mean that's the way it is but in some
states you can do a lot less than in
other states in in New York I think
you're gonna have to go around with
masks for a while you're gonna have to
do you're gonna have to do separation
you want your distancing you're gonna
have to do that for a while but some
states are doing so well and others are
I have to tell you I got to know the
governors and with a few exceptions
be honest because they're just political
machines and anything you say it's
always going to be like what's good
politically because we shouldn't be in
that position I will say that they
really have done a lot of them great job
and we've worked with them we had no
there were no ventilators we're building
with a king of I said with the king of
ventilators you look at the testing we
tested now six and a half million people
the next highest is I think it's two and
a half million people either Germany or
South Korea and South Korea thinks we've
done an incredible job they're saying
the job he's a friend of mine president
mone he said the job you've done on
testing and the job we've done on
ventilators we have one of the it's it's
one of the greatest build ups we've ever
had in this country since certainly the
Second World War about you know Gretchen
Whitmer the governor in Michigan she's
saying this morning on TV we don't have
the reagents we need we don't have the
swabs we need she's still saying that
she can't get the testing that she will
look look we had a phone call five days
ago with the governor's I was on the
call with Vice President Mike Pence who
has done a great job he's the head of
the committee of the task force every
governor there we asked him what do you
need not one governor needed anything
now all of a sudden you see her on the
Sunday I watched it well we should get
this and we should get that should he
get back to running her state properly
because she should have brought it up
but a phone call I was on that call for
an hour and a half the call I stayed
right till the end and at the end I said
does anybody need anything
we had one Governor Inslee who's always
wanting something and frankly he didn't
do a very good job when nursing homes as
far as I'm concerned state of Washington
and he said we need swaps I said why
don't you get him yourself but if you
can't we'll get him and I could say the
same thing about her but here's the
thing why didn't they why didn't they
bring this up I had a Brett you know
about the call it was in every week or
two weeks we'll have a call all 50
governors I believe were on that call
the last statement okay who needs
something none of them many of them
spoke nobody needed other than
Washington wanted swabs which are easy
to get
so let me ask you that the man who
you're about to hear from was told he
had a 20% chance to live
he had Kovan 19 he was really about
shape young I think he's about 40 39
years old actually 39 years old but he
did recover and here's Danny lame-o's
from Grand Island Nebraska okay
president Trump this is Danny again here
grinning abrasca with the FDA approving
reservoir as a drug of choice to help
fight this which is drug I was on what
do we get to do and put in place to make
sure that there's enough of this drug
available for everybody so we're doing
that it's a great question because it's
a very hard drug to make and it takes a
period of time and is made by Gilead and
I know that Danny gave that drug a lot
of credit for saving his life I think
that's correct Danny but Danny I believe
gave a lot of credit to that drug for
saving his life we are pushing it really
hard we're also pushing something else
the vaccines we are very confident we're
going to have a vaccine at the end of
the year by the end of the year have a
vaccine by the end of this we think
we're going to have a vaccine by the end
of this year and we're pushing very hard
you know we're building supply lines now
we don't even have the final vaccine
Johnson & Johnson if you look at Johnson
& Johnson is doing it we have many
companies are I think close because I
meet with the heads of them and I find
it a very interesting subject because
it's so important but I think we'll have
a vaccine by the end of the year we're
also pushing it look we're doing things
at the FDA that's never happened before
we're getting approval so fast like as
an example with Gilead on the new render
server that's gonna be that's that's a
game-changer because it's a 31% step
it's a step it's a 31% step and then
there'll be at 50% like AIDS
what's happened with AIDS we had AIDS
was a scourge all over the world it was
you were dead it was a death certificate
and then all of a sudden they came up
with some camp and now we have we will
be aids-free within eight years we
started 10 years should have started in
the previous administration they did
nothing
so mr. president at my administration 10
years
to prove this from death severe yes he's
asking how do you get it are you gonna
use the defense production act to get
well he got it I'll tell Danny got it
fortunately and Danny is David Danny
gave it credit for saving his life we
are putting the full power and might
behind this drug with that being said
it's a very hard drug there are others
that are much easier to make it takes a
little period of time to make it the
company is a great company done
incredible work over the years they are
pushing absolutely as fast you know this
isn't something like let's build
machines or let's this is a very
delicate balance but we're pushing very
very hard on Brenda said we're so our
next question is from a teacher in
Chesterfield Virginia hmm hi president
Trump my name is Kristin Marie I'm an
algebra teacher in Virginia we
appreciate you and support you and all
you're doing I would like to see what
your ideas are for getting us teachers
back into our classrooms we don't want
to be our school teaching we want to be
in the classrooms with our students so
what's your ideas for getting us back in
our classrooms and getting the doors
open well I would answer that mr. just
one second a lot of questions tonight
not only from teachers but also the
other side from students talking about
kovat 19 real quick put them together
here Rebecca Johnson hi I'm Rebecca and
I live in Minneapolis Minnesota I'm
gonna be a freshman in high school next
year and I worry that coronavirus is
gonna come back how will they feel safe
going back to school if a second wave
hits so when you go back and you have
one problem that is a bigger problem and
that's teachers over 60 or 65 years old
the teachers because I think that
Kristin or Rebecca got to be in great
shape and they may weigh or mash for a
while and they may be separated further
than what they're used to and I think
they're gonna be in great shape but we
have to get our schools back this
virtual teaching is wonderful and you
know frankly it's taking a very positive
step I mean I could say I've had now
essentially board meetings and meetings
with governors and other people with you
know using they call it Ella
right Ella and it's not bad but there's
nothing like having a meeting I still
think you're never going to replace that
no they're gonna go back we have
to have our students go back to school
my biggest thing because I really feel
the students are a great shape they're
gonna be all of the things we have to do
all of the things but I do worry about
teachers at a certain age
Rebecca's young and she's going to be
fine
the students are going to be fine but I
really think that you know if you take a
look
Kristen is going to be fine but if you
have a teacher that's 65 or 70 years old
and has diabetes that one I think
they're gonna have to sit it out for a
little while
mr.president less we come up with the
vaccine sooner are you going to urge the
nation's universities and schools to go
back in September I am I want him to go
back we have to get our country back
yeah I don't want to do this forever I
watched a very good government former
governor of Indiana proceeding he
preceded Mike Pence good governor and
he's the head of Purdue it's a great
school and I saw him the other day he
wants to go back he's going back Purdue
big school fantastic they're going back
we have to go back we have to go back
and whatever it is I would say with the
exception of teachers at a certain age
they may maybe they should wait till
this thing passes it will pass you know
it's going to pass and a lot of people
say we have to get the vaccine we'll
certainly would do and we have to get
therapeutics I'd rather have right now
therapeutics that make people better
that's where rendus Avars is really good
you did talk a lot about hydroxy
chlorinating and there were some studies
that came out that questioned the the
cardiac tie but when he got at one study
but there were studies that came out
that say it's very good too and I'll
tell you what I've had three calls in
the last three days four days of people
that took it and they're giving it
credit for saving their lives and other
state you know other countries are using
into them they're going they're bragging
about it you look at their numbers
here's what we've been reduced to in
this country the Democrats the radical
left whatever you would rather see
people I'm gonna be very nice I'm not
gonna say die I'm gonna say would rather
see people not get well because they
think I'm
gonna get credit if you know
hydroxychloroquine works and I don't
want to cry don't care about it I have
nothing to do with it by the way
everyone said I own the company I have
nothing to do with hydroxychloroquine
other than if it worked it would be
great it would be so good for an ape
because it would save people but you
know we've had some very good you look
at there are certain countries that
swear by it they have a much lower
number
you know the countries I'm talking about
you're putting your real chips on the
vaccine being fast well I think we're
gonna have a vaccine by the end of the
and now the doctors would say well you
shouldn't say that I'll say what I think
I've met with the heads of the big
companies these are great companies yeah
I think we're gonna have a vaccine much
sooner rather than later I think it will
be I think that will be done I would
rather have frankly therapeutic meaning
something to make people better if not a
cure at least a therapeutic and you know
that look we started the other day with
Gilead I really think so but we're gonna
have other things and it could be that
hydroxy is going to be we don't lose
anything with hydroxy it's been out
there bred it's been out there for so
many years then they start doing the
false reports that's making me it's it's
been used for numerous things for many
years people aren't dying from it and
but there and yeah they don't want to
see a good result and that's there are
some questions that deal with looking
back Lesley is one of them Lesley
Caulfield from New Jersey has our next
question for the day's President Trump
it's been widely reported that the
threat of the corona virus was included
in your daily intelligence briefings for
weeks prior to the first confirmed case
in the u.s. can you please explain to us
why you did not act sooner to prepare
this country for this pandemic okay I
love the question actually because what
I did is I wearily I closed our country
to China Nancy Pelosi was a month later
saying it's gonna pass everybody even
Tony
ouchy was saying it's gonna pass not
going to be a big deal
Schumer was talking about all sorts of
that this is long after I close the
country they called me a racist they
said xenophobic Biden said he was
xenophobic Biden has now written a
letter of apology
because I did the right thing I saved
hundreds of thousands of lives okay
she's asking me the question about
intelligence I have the head of the
intelligence agencies here today and
here's the exact thing and we have it
it's going to be released tomorrow the
next day but I released it today on
January 23rd I was told that there could
be a virus coming in but it was of no
real import in other words it wasn't all
we got to do something we got to do
something it was a brief conversation
and it was only on January 23rd shortly
thereafter I closed down the country to
China and we had 20 people 21 people in
the room I was the only one that wanted
to close it down very good people in the
room very well-meaning but take a look
on I think it was February 26th Nancy
Pelosi is let's dance in the streets of
Chinatown to show that it's not gonna
hurt us in other words I'm not blaming
her for it but nobody thought this was
going to happen but her in January it's
such an important question to me because
they think that months earlier we were
told about this that we should have done
something about it
China didn't even know for a period of
time it got out China should have
stopped it but she I didn't they didn't
know and they wouldn't let us in we
wanted to go into China they didn't want
us to go in because they didn't want to
have a see it maybe they were worried
about competence maybe they were worried
about something else but the question is
good and here's the final answer the
intelligence agencies told me at the
23rd shortly thereafter I closed down
the country but I didn't do it because
of what they said because they said it
very matter-of-factly it was not a big
deal and the intelligence agencies which
have now now because before they weren't
which are now very competently run with
some great people and some great people
coming the intelligence agencies will
tell you that tomorrow so when when you
did stop traveling from China 40,000
people
came back to this country you they were
American citizens but you said they were
tested who tested them and we were
tested well the different states they
were tested they were quarantined when
they were sick and they came back I
spoke with Ron DeSantis
two days ago he called me he said you
know the 40,000 people that came back
the ones that went to Florida he said we
put them through the grill we had people
quarantined we had people tested you
could ask the governor I'd you know
there's one example but other governors
did the same thing if they were doing
their job but I had to let them come
back I actually said maybe we could keep
him there for a while these are American
citizens I had a letter come back Martha
so he had 40,000 people now when the
Democrat said it he said he closed the
border but he let 40,000 they don't say
there were American citizens I did the
right thing but when they came back they
were tested some were tested probably
and not as good as they could have been
I can tell you Florida tested the people
very very well and look how low the
numbers are in Florida they've done a
great job President carved on the wall
behind me is Abraham Lincoln's second
inaugural address and the quote with
malice toward none with charity for all
let us bind up the nation's wounds words
you know meant to heal a nation
devastated by civil war we obviously
live in a divided time as well you know
that well your choice even of this
hallowed place for this virtual Town
Hall is creating controversy criticism
what do you say to people who say this
is not the right venue for this do you
know I didn't know that it was creating
criticism and I did say this would be
nice but I thought it was your choice
not ours and I had not heard what can
you criticize it's I don't think it's
ever been done what we're doing tonight
here and I think it's great for the
American people to see there's a great
work of art aside from the fact that
that was a great man there's a great
work of art it's one of the greatest
sculptures one of the greatest statues
to me anywhere in the world then you can
go to Italy you can go anywhere that's
to me one of the greats and I didn't
know there was controversy why is there
controversy some from Capitol Hill sent
a letter that it's not the right place
they're not not the right site but as
far as bringing America together do you
think you're doing that I think we're
winning very big and then we had a
horrible thing happened we're winning
bigger than we've ever won before right
and I think that winning ultimately is
going to bring this country together I'm
shocked that during a crisis it would be
so
artisan you know when you see all these
committees seven or eight committees we
haven't even started and they have all
these committees looking for trouble
just looking for trouble every enemy I
have is put on a Democrat committee and
I was surprised you know they did the
impeachment hoax it was a total hoax
over a phone call that was a perfect
call and we had tremendous when you look
at the house I think it was 196 to
nothing the Republicans said there was
great unity and the Senate the same
thing with all of that unity we have in
one sense we have great unity in another
sense I think they're gonna come along I
mean you know I certainly hope so but
the main thing I have to do is bring our
country back and I want to get it back
to where it was or maybe beyond where it
was you know we have tremendous stimulus
all the money we've been talking about
so far tonight I think next year's going
to be a phenomenal economic year we can
never forget all the people that have
died the souls that have been lost in
this horrible thing that shouldn't
shouldn't have happened just shouldn't
have happened it's such a horrible thing
and there's a lot what going on about
finding out the answer to that because
this is something that you'd never have
happened it stretch you want to talk to
you a little bit more about China in
just a moment but I mentioned winning
and there's a race to win on the vaccine
between countries in the world so
pushing this vaccine development in
order to get it to go faster leads to
human trials people volunteering
basically be injected with kovat 19 are
you concerned about the optics where the
risk of that in that push no because
they're volunteers they know what
they're getting into there in many cases
very good people they want to help the
process look a vaccine has never gone
like it's gone we're so far ahead of any
vaccine ever in history you know these
things would take two four five six
years ten years I think we're gonna have
a vaccine I'm telling you by the end of
the week I think we're going to have a
very another country could beat us I'm
gonna really say something that is not
like me and it's not like the two of you
I know you and it's not like you I don't
care I just want to get a vaccine that
works I really don't care if it's
another country I'll take my hat off to
them we have to come up with a vaccine
we're working with other countries we're
working with Australia we're working
with UK I spoke with the other day your
prime minister of UK right it's Boris he
he's a victim of what happened he
thought it was over
he thought it was over it was vicious
and he made it he's a great guy and he
made it but he had first-hand experience
the ultimate first-hand experience mr.
president next question there is Dina
Rubio she's the co manager of a
restaurant down in West Palm Beach
Florida and you know well here's her
question we're facing the shortage of
supplies due to the closure of chicken
pork and beef plants prices are going up
in the restaurant industry it's finding
even more obstacles to stay afloat my
question is how could we manage to keep
working with very slim profit margins to
begin with and I've sort of shortage
pricing Chris at this point and even
when we do open our dining rooms we will
be having limited sitting available
right so the restaurant business is a
tough business to start off with not an
easy business we're doing a number of
things number one the supply chain is
going to be in great shape I did the
production defense production Act we did
things the problem with the supply chain
is you have people that have gotten sick
with the kovat 19 you've had the people
and they've gotten sick they're getting
better and they're all getting better
and you can't make them work I don't
want them to work frankly if they're not
feeling great but we did something the
other day which you read about which was
a great shock to the system in a
positive way we have tremendous we have
tremendous supply we have tremendous
demand we have to get it from supply to
the people to the restaurants and we're
doing that really very well
two days ago I signed this it's coming
along really good they'll have now the
bigger problem is what's going to happen
with the restaurant so we're not going
to have any chain problem the bigger
problem is what are you gonna do with a
restaurant which was you know a nice
little business but all of a sudden they
have half the number of seats if they go
eventually we're gonna have all those
seats back you're gonna have all those
seats I want to sit next to people I
don't want to have all this spread out
like even the way we're doing we're
doing this we're doing this interview
tonight look how far away you are look
how far away you are
you know normally we would be sitting
together and would have a nice interview
of course in this particular location
this isn't so bad but no we have to get
our life back we have to get our country
back we have to get the world back we
want to have if we have a stadium in
Alabama that holds a hundred and ten
thousand people against LSU I went there
we want to have a hundred and ten
thousand we don't want to have 25,000
people or 40,000 people and that'll
happen maybe it's going to be a vaccine
or maybe it's going to be that this
virus will pass it will go will it come
back it might it could some people say
yes but it will pass I want to go back
to the meat processing plants because
there's some controversy surrounding
that Danny lame-o's who you saw before
who had the REM disavow said it helped
him survive his father worked in one of
those in Nebraska in the meat plants and
some people there say that they're you
know they have plastic between them but
they're too close together a lot of
immigrants working there who are
concerned but they can't turn down a
paycheck to go back there so they're you
know Smith the Smithfield plant and
Crete wanted to shut down for two weeks
and then the executive order change that
so there's some pushback on that
decision by you what do you say to those
people well the companies really wanted
it and the employees have to want to
work now if they don't want to work
that's one thing but they are working
and they need the money and the
companies are doing they're great
companies you know these have been these
are the biggest companies in the world
in terms of delivery and in terms of all
of the things they do to get it from
literally the ranch of the farm into the
hands of the consuming public but I
think it's all working out you know the
the numbers are heading in the right
direction the numbers look the biggest
thing we can do to solve every problem
is get rid of the plague I call it the
plague if we get rid of the plague all
these problems go away very quickly some
of those meat processing areas are
hotspots right now they're hotspots and
they're moving them and they did put up
plastic but now they're going to move
them in some cases further away and
certain plants don't have any problem at
all you know you have plans with no
problem at all then you have somewhere
it was a hot spot those people are
tending to get better very quickly I
think you know Danny is an example I
hope his father's gonna be okay too
but it's all working out it's all
working out it's horrible that we have
to go through it but it's all working on
our next question is from Carol McNeil a
retired teacher in Bluffton South
Carolina
a family member who lives in a very
exclusive and expensive assisted living
center in the Boston area was recently
diagnosed with coronavirus what will be
done both in the short term and in the
long term to protect the vulnerable in
nursing homes senior housing and
assisted living centers so the nursing
home problem that's your Ground Zero
it really is Ground Zero we first heard
about it I did in Washington when so
many people were in the state of
Washington with so many people died in a
single nursing home and you realized
immediately there's a vulnerability
there what we're doing is legislation
immediately as to how many people can be
in some people made some terrible
mistakes they were putting other people
into empty areas in nursing homes that
were sick and that affected the people
in the nursing homes because the one
thing about this disease that
everybody's learned very easily and very
quickly is the way it's so contagious it
is the most contagious thing people have
seen so in 1917 we had a horrible in
that case it was a flu right you
remember the Spanish flu I've so much
has been written about it now of course
it's the hottest everybody that writes a
book about the Spanish from 1917 it
killed between a hundred and I guess
fifty to a hundred million people it
probably ended the first world war
because the soldiers were getting sick
it was the worst the world has ever seen
that we know of we have something that's
different it's not as powerful but it's
far more contagious with regard to the
nursing homes one of the questions that
came to my mind when I watched the
comfort leaving Manhattan you know in
the Javits Center why were these people
next to each other like this in nursing
homes when we had all this excess
capacity and beds why weren't they sent
there so on that one you have to ask the
governor and in the case the governor's
because all I can do is provide the
space they're running their state as you
understand and that's the way it should
be they run their state through mayors
and through this and that you know bring
it down local and bring it down to a
point but we provided 2,900 beds in the
convention center
on top of that we brought in the comfort
they did a phenomenal job and the
comfort wasn't meant for the kovat 19
the comfort was meant for people that
had car accidents everything else that
we found out there were no accidents
because nobody was driving we had very
few accidents but it wasn't meant for
that what we did is we converted it to
that but still they didn't use it much
and I think the number is now getting
better we just moved the Comfort we're
going to move it someplace else probably
perhaps for some other kind of problem
but we had the comfort there and we
built in the in the Javits Center we
built over 2,000 beds and by the way
built in like five days by the Army
Corps of Engineers the Army Corps of
Engineers have done one of the greatest
jobs anyone's ever seen including the
fact that we happen to be building a
wall on the southern border that's now
up to 172 miles likley how concerned are
you about hospitals that are not dealing
with Kovac 19 are primarily not and
they're letting people go now closing we
have to get elective surgeries called
and we have to let them come back it's
okay with us again that's up to the
governor's you have some hospitals where
they have almost no kovat and they have
the hospital essentially you can't go
into elective surgery meaning a surgery
well in some cases it's cancer where
they they're waiting long that's not a
good thing to be waiting long
so it's such a they have to get back
they have to let these hospitals because
the hospitals are legitimately you know
with you think they're making a lot of
money they're losing a fortune they have
to let those hospitals reopen and get
back to elective surgery and there are
many hospitals right now that could be
doing that the gut that's up to the
governor's that's not up to me